SEAN HANNITY.
>> Sean: GREAT SHOW.
WOW!
DID YOU NOT LOVE THE RALLY IF
GRAND RAPIDS?
UNBELIEVABLE.
WE HAVE THE HIGHLIGHTS.
IF YOU MISSED IT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
RUSH LIMBAUGH JOINING US AND
DON JR. JOINING US, MOMENTS
AWAY.
BUT FIRST, DONALD TRUMP
WRAPPED UP A MASSIVE RALLY IN
WESTERN MICHIGAN WHERE 140,000
PEOPLE WANTED TO GO A 15,000
ARENA.
HE WAS TOUTING HIS IMPRESSIVE
RECORD OF ACCOMPLISHMENTS, THE
ONES THE MEDIA NEVER TALK
ABOUT.
DESPITES FACING POLITICAL
WITCH HUNT FOR TWO YEARS THE
PRESIDENT GUIDED THE COUNTRY
ON THE RIGHT PATH WITH
REGULATIONS AND TAX CUTS AND
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 70 YEARS.
A BOOMING ECONOMY.
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, ASIAN AMERICANS,
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE AND
YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE U.S. IS NOW AGAIN THE
LEADER AND THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD.
WHY DO YOU THINK SO MANY
PEOPLE WANT TO COME HERE?
THE HATERS WERE WRONG.
THE MEDIA LIED FOR TWO
CONSECUTIVE PLUS YEARS.
THE DEEP STATE THANKFULLY HAS
NOW BEEN EXPOSED.
THOSE RESPONSIBLE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
FOR THE PRESIDENT WHO PROMISED
TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE WEAR THAT
HAT, IT'S A TRIGGER FOR THE
LEFT.
PROMISES MADE, PROMISES KEPT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: THIS HAS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE COUPLE OF
WEEKS FOR AMERICA.
[CHEERS]
>> President Trump: THE
ECONOMY IS ROARING.
THE ISIS CALIPHATE IS DEFEATED
100%.
AND AFTER THREE YEARS OF LIES
AND SMEARS AND SLANDER, THE
RUSSIA HOAX IS FINALLY DEAD.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT, THE
CROWD ON FIRE TONIGHT.
OH, I FORGOT TO TELL YOU.
WE HAVE A HUGE ANNOUNCEMENT.
BIG AT THE END OF THE SHOW.
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHILE WE HAVE BEEN BUSY
REPORTING THE TRUTH, WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN THE REST OF THE
MEDIA?
THEY HAVE BEEN WAGING THROUGH
A PSYCHOTIC RAGE.
A POLITICAL WAR AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
AND ALSO WE, THE PEOPLE, THE
SMELLY WALMART PEOPLE, THE
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLES, AND
WHILE WE HAVE BEEN DRIVEN BY
FACTS, WHILE WE DON'T RUSH TO
JUDGMENT AND WE BELIEVE IN DUE
PROCESS, THEY HAVE BEEN
BLINDED BY HATRED AND RAGE.
THAT IS WHY WE MAKE SURE WE
GET IT RIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM.
CLEARLY ALMOST EVERY BIG STORY
THEY GET IT WRONG.
THAT IS WHY POOR RACHEL MADDOW
WITH HER TINFOIL HAT
CONSPIRACY HAT LOST ALL
CREDIBLE.
WHY CNN AND NBC ARE NOW
EXPERIENCING DRAMATIC RATINGS
DECLINE PRECIPITOUSLY IT'S
UNREAL AND DESERVED.
THAT IS WHY THE TINFOIL HAT
CONSPIRACY THEORIST, ADAM
SCHIFF THE ONLY ONE LEFT
STANDING FACING URGENT CALLS,
RIGHTLY SO, TO RESIGN FROM THE
POSITION ATOP THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
CONTINUE TO PROMOTE FALSE
NARRATIVE IS ALARMING.
THE FINDINGS EXPOSED YOU AS
HAVING ABUSED YOUR POSITION TO
KNOWINGLY PROMOLT FALSE
INFORMATION.
AS SUCH WE HAVE NO FACE IN THE
ABILITY TO DISCHARGE THE
DUTIES IN A MANNER CONSISTENT
WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND URGE THE
IMMEDIATE RESIGNATION AS
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE.
>> I THINK IT'S IMMORAL.
I THINK IT'S UNETHICAL.
I THINK IT'S UNPATRIOTIC.
YES, I THINK IT'S CORRUPT.
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S OKAY THAT
HIS ATTORNEY LIED TO OUR
COMMITTEE.
THERE IS A DIFFERENT WORD FOR
THAT THAN "COLLUSION."
IT'S CALLED "COMPROMISE."
I WILL NOT YIELD.
>> YOU MADE THINGS ABOUT ALL
OF US THAT WE SHOULD GET THE
RESPONSIBILITY --
>> I WILL NOT --
>> Sean: REMEMBER, IT WAS
KNOWN LEAKER AND LIAR ADAM
SCHIFF, WE CALL HIM "THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF" ON THIS
PROGRAM WHO CLAIMED TO HAVE
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
PROMISING THAT.
NOW THAT ROBERT MUELLER'S ALL
POWERFUL 22 MONTHS, $25
MILLION PROBE FOUND NOTHING AS
DID THE NINE-MONTH
INVESTIGATION OF THE F.B.I.
AND THE HOUSE INTEL, SENATE
INTEL COMMITTEES, HE IS IN
CONGRESS, STILL CLAIMING TO
HAVE THE SMOKING GUN EVIDENCE
THAT THE INVESTIGATIONS DID
NOT FIND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WELL, HE IS
CALLING OUT THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: LITTLE
PENCIL NECK ADAM SCHIFF.
HE HAS GOT THE SMALLEST,
THINNEST NECK I'VE EVER SEEN.
HE IS NOT A LONG BALL HITTER.
BUT I SAW HIM TODAY.
"WELL, WE DON'T REALLY KNOW.
THERE COULD STILL HAVE BEEN
SOME RUSSIA COLLUSION."
SICK, SICK.
THESE ARE SICK PEOPLE.
AND THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY BECAUSE IT'S
ALL LIES.
AND THEY KNOW IT'S LIES.
>> Sean: THERE HAS TO BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
HE WAS ON FIRE TONIGHT.
WE HAVE INVITED MANY TIMES THE
COWARDLY SCHIFF ON THIS
PROGRAM TO PRESENT HIS DAMNING
EVIDENCE, THE ONE THAT THE
F.B.I., THE HOUSE INTEL, THE
SENATE COMMITTEE AND ROBERT
MUELLER DIDN'T FIND ABOUT
RUSSIA COLLUSION.
COME MAKE YOUR CASE.
HE HAS ALWAYS DECLINED COMING
ON THE PROGRAM.
I OFFERED THREE HOURS OF
RADIO.
THAT IS BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN
LYING TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
GUESS WHAT?
WE ARE ANNOUNCING TONIGHT ON
THIS PROGRAM THAT I HAVE MY
OWN DOSSIER ON THE COWARDLY
SCHIFF.
BASICALLY HIM IN HIS OWN WORDS
FOR TWO-PLUS YEARS.
WE WILL PLAY HIM IN HIS OWN
WORDS.
REMEMBER, HE WAS ACTUALLY
CAUGHT ON TAPE COLLUDING WITH
PEOPLE THAT HE ACTUALLY
BELIEVED WERE RUSSIAN SOURCES,
TRYING TO GET COMPROMISING
MATERIALS ON TRUMP TO IMPACT
OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM?
OH, HE IS CAUGHT ON TAPE
COLLUDING.
YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS UP.
THIS IS HOW DUMB THIS MAN IS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> AND SHE MET WITH TRUMP AND
SHE BROUGHT HIM, A GIRL,
CELEBRITY.
OLGA KNOWN AS A PERSON WITH A
STRANGE REPUTATION.
>> OLGA, HOW DO YOU SPELL HER
NAME?
>> OLGA.
>> WHAT IS THE NAY CHURE OF
THE COMPROMISE?
>> THERE WERE PICTURES OF
NAKED TRUMP.
>> SO PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF
THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL BE BACK IN TOUCH WITH
YOU THROUGH OUR STAFF TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO OBTAIN THE
MATERIALS FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND THE F.B.I.
I APPRECIATE YOUR REACHING OUT
TO US.
>> Sean: LIKE THE GREATEST
TAPE WE EVER PLAY.
HE IS CAUGHT ON TAPE COLLUDING
WITH RUSSIANS.
UNBELIEVABLE.
NOW CALIFORNIA 28th
DISTRICT, YOU OBVIOUSLY COULD
DO BETTER.
SCHIFF SHOULD RESIGN AS A
DISGRACE.
BUT SCHIFF IS NOT THE ONLY BAD
ACTOR WHO HAS BEEN UTTERLY HUE
MAILATED BY THE PROBE.
ALSO DISGRACED THE C.I.A.
DIRECTOR TURNED NBC, MSNB
TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY THEORY
NETWORK HACK JOHN BRENNAN.
HE CALLED THE PRESIDENT ON
MULTIPLE OCCASIONS A TRAITOR.
PUSHING CONSPIRACY THEORIES AS
UTTER FACT ALMOST EVERY DAY.
HE WAS LYING ON AN EXTREME
LEVEL.
TONIGHT WE ARE LEARNING
SOMETHING DAMNING ABOUT JOHN
BRENNAN.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE STORY.
RAND PAUL EARLIER TODAY
TWEETING OUT THAT THE
HIGH-LEVEL SPACE THAT THE FAKE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
STEELE DOSSIER WITH THE
RUSSIAN LIES INCLUDING IN THE
INTELLIGENCE REPORT THAT
BRENNAN SHOULD BE ASKED TO NOW
TESTIFY UNDER OATH IN
CONGRESS.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
IN OTHER WORDS BRENNAN USED
HIS OFFICIAL POSITION AS
C.I.A. DIRECTOR TO VALIDATE
THE PHONY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER.
WAS HE INVOLVED IN THE HOAX?
WAS HE TRYING TO SET TRUMP UP
FROM THE GET-GO?
THAT WOULD BE A BLATANT ABUSE
OF POWER.
HOW DOES THIS CONMAN HAVE A
JOB AT NBC?
ANDY LACK, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TALK TO HIM.
WE TAKE THIS PROMISE EVERY
SERIOUSLY.
EVERY NIGHT, EVERY SINGLE
PERSON, EVERY MEMBER OF THE
DEEP STATE, NOT RANK AND FILE
F.B.I.
THEY'RE AWESOME.
THE GREATEST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY ON THE PLANET.
THE OTHERS, THE FEW WE WILL
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE.
WITH THE HELP OF DEDICATED
INVESTIGATORS EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW AND EQUAL
APPLICATION OF THE LAWS WILL
HAPPEN.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WILL
BE UPHELD.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE RANKING INTEL
MEMBER DOUG COLLINS.
TODAY HE FOLLOWED UP AGAIN,
RELEASING EVEN MORE
TRANSCRIPTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE'S CLOSED DOOR
HEARINGS.
THINGS WE NEVER HEARD BEFORE.
THIS INCLUDED TESTIMONY FROM
NELLUE OHR WHO WORKED HAND IN
HAND WITH THE FUSION GPS.
AND HE WORKED WITH BRUCE OHR.
ONE OF THE FOURTH HIGHEST
MEMBER OF D.O.J.
WE LEARNED TODAY THAT NELLIE
OHR ADMITTED TO MEETING WITH
CHRISTOPHER STEELE A DAY
BEFORE THEY LAUNCHED THE
INTELLIGENCE PROBE OF TRUMP
AND RUSSIA IN 2016.
ONE DAY BEFORE.
SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
HER D.O.J. HUSBAND BRUCE OHR
WAS AT THE MEETING.
ACCORDING TO HER WORDS AND THE
TRANSCRIPTS WE LEARN THAT
NELLIE OHR WAS INSTRUCTED A TO
DIG UP DIRT ON PAUL MANAFORT
ANDS MICHAEL FLYNN.
LO AND BEHOLD, GUESS WHAT?
WHO WAS TARGETED BY THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
PAUL MANAFORT AND MICHAEL
FLYNN.
IT DOESN'T STOP THERE.
SHE ADMITS TO TARGETING DONALD
TRUMP JR. AND EVEN THE
PRESIDENT'S WIFE MELANIA.
DON'T FORGET, AS REPORTED BY
"THE HILL'S" JOHN SOLOMON,
NELLIE OHR GAVE HER HUSBAND A
FLASH DRIVE WITH THE BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES IN
THE HOPE HE WOULD DISSEMINATE
IT.
IT WAS LEAKED TO THE MEDIA
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
WHY?
TO INFLUENCE THE ELECTION ON
BEHALF OF HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT IS NOT ALL.
NOW THANKS TO OHR'S TESTIMONY,
WE KNOW A KEY SOURCE FOR
FASHION G.P.S. IS -- FUSION
G.P.S. IS THE SAME UKRAINIAN
LAWMAKER WHO IS ACCUSED OF
TIMING THE RELEASE OF THE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT BACK IN 2016.
IN ORDER TO HELP HILLARY
CLINTON WIN THE ELECTION.
UKRAINIAN INTERFERENCE WITH
THE ELECTION, WITH HILLARY AND
THERE IS A TAPE IN THAT CASE.
A COURT IN UKRAINE RULED IN
DECEMBER THOSE ACTIONS
AMOUNTED TO MEDDLING IN THE
2016 AMERICAN PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
SO, YEAH, THERE WAS COLLUSION
IN 2016.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, THE D.N.C.
NOW ON THE GOOD SIDE.
LET NOT YOUR HEARTS BE
TROUBLED.
THE DEEP STATE'S DAY OF
RECKONING IS JUST AROUND THE
CORNER.
NEXT WEEK, CONGRESSMAN DEVIN
NUNES WILL BE ISSUING CRIMINAL
REFERS.
MANY OF THEM.
TARGETING THOSE WHO ARE LIED
TO CONGRESS.
COMMITTED CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY.
THEY ARE GOING TO BE PEOPLE
NOW INVESTIGATED AS WE HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR, FOR OVER TWO
YEARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST NIGHT ON
THE PROGRAM, HE VOWED TO
RELEASE ALL FISA DOCUMENTS
SURROUNDING CARTER PAGE.
A TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE.
THEY SPIED ON HIM AND DENIED
HIM HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
AT THE HEIGHT OF ELECTION THAT
GAVE THEM A BACKDOOR TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
A FEW CORRUPT DEEP STATE
BUREAUCRATS WITH THE HELP OF
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
PHONY LYING RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
EARLIER, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
THIS TO SAY ABOUT THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY
THAT THE MEDIA IGNORED.
TAKE A WATCH.
>> President Trump: THE
RUSSIA WITCH HUNT WAS A PLAN
BY THOSE WHO LOST THE ELECTION
TO TRY AND ILLEGALLY REGAIN
POWER BY FRAMING INNOCENT
AMERICANS, MANY OF THEM.
THEY SUFFERED WITH AN
ELABORATE HOAX.
THEY WANTED TO DESTROY A
MOVEMENT LIKE OUR COUNTRY HAS
NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO NOW
DECIDE WHETHER THEY WILL
CONTINUE DEFRAUDING THE PUBLIC
WITH RIDICULOUS
[bleep]
[APPLAUSE]
>> President Trump: PARTISAN
INVESTIGATIONS OR WHETHER THEY
WILL APOLOGIZE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I LONG SAID THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE
DISRUPTOR WE NEED IN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
HE IS NOT THE ESTABLISHMENT.
THE SWAMP NEEDS TO BE DRAINED.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ICONOCLASTIC.
FIGHTING TO KEEP PROMISES.
IMAGINE THAT FROM A
POLITICIAN.
HE HAS FROM THE GET-GO
CHALLENGED ALL CONVENTIONAL
THINKING AND IN DOING SO
EXPOSED A DARK BUREAUCRATIC
UNDERBELLY THAT IS WITHIN OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND DOING SO, HE REALLY IS
MAKING AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
HIS STATISTICS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES.
ACCORDING TO THE OBAMA FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ERIC HOLDER,
AMERICA, THE COUNTRY WE LOVE
THAT BEAT BACK FASCISM AND
NAZIISM AND COMMUNISM IN
IMPERIAL JAPAN IS NOT A GREAT
COUNTRY.
I NEVER WAS.
>> WHEN I HEAR THE THICKS LIKE
LET'S MAKE -- THINGS LIKE
LET'S MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN, WHEN DID YOU THINK
AMERICA GREAT?
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T WHEN
PEOPLE WERE ENSLAVED AND IT
WASN'T WHEN WOMEN DIDN'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
IT CERTAINLY WASN'T WHEN THE
LGBT COMMUNITY DENIED RIGHTS
OF WHICH IT WAS ENTITLED.
>> IT TAKES US BACK TO AN
AMERICAN PAST THAT NEVER IN
FACT REALLY EXISTED.
>> Sean: NEVER A PERFECT
COUNTRY.
BUT WE HAVE PAID THE PRICE FOR
FREEDOM.
FOR MORE PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF
THIS EARTH.
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A COUNTRY
THAT ACCUMULATED MORE POWER,
ABUSED IT LESS AND USED IT FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF THE HUMAN
CONDITION MORE THAN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
I'M PRETTY SURE HOLDER WON'T
BE THE LAST SUCCESSFUL WEALTHY
FIGURE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
REALLY?
YOU WANT TO RUN ON TRASHING
THE GREATNESS OF AMERICA?
TONIGHT THE GOOD PEOPLE OF
MICHIGAN, THEY HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT TAKE.
COME 2020, AMERICA'S GREATNESS
WILL PREVAIL.
LET'S WATCH.
>> President Trump: EACH OF
US HERE TONIGHT IS UNITED BY
THE SAME TIMELESS VALUES.
WE BELIEVE IN THE AMERICAN
CONSTITUTION.
AND THE AMERICAN RULE OF LAW.
[APPLAUSE]
WE BELIEVE IN THE DIGNITY OF
WORK.
AND THE SANCTITY OF LIFE.
WE BELIEVE THAT FAITH AND
FAMILY, NOT GOVERNMENT AND
BUREAUCRACY, ARE THE TRUE
AMERICAN WAY.
WE BELIEVE IN RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY, THE RIGHT TO FREE